E aí
[Música]
o Olá a todos quando o professor Entra
na sala costuma haver sempre alguma
referência ou havia porque o professor
Marcos quando olhamos para um professor
não vemos quem temos à frente nos
lembramos dos professores que nos
marcaram no nosso percurso no nosso
estudo Com certeza a professores aqui e
com certeza a outras pessoas que não são
pessoas têm outras profissões
e o vem falar educação e para isso vou
começar com um pequeno teste e esse
teste é
perceber
que o nosso cérebro se tiver um problema
não arranjo submeter a uma cirurgia uma
operação e Vamos confiar em alguém que
pode ter um espaço como aquele que está
a preto e branco ou pode ter um espaço
mais recente contra tecnologia e o nosso
cérebro é demasiado precioso para ser
confiado a algo que naquela imagem a
preto e branco nos pode sugerir que não
será possível curar os nossos problema
no cérebro e isso é muito importante
todos percebemos e sempre perguntar e
responder a mentalmente onde é que
estavam ter a vossa cirurgia na sala a
preto e branco ou nesta sala mais atual
mais moderna a resposta penso que será
óbvia e por isso pergunto os que é que
conhece a imagem a preto e branco e se
ela não continua como está na imagem a
cores que é uma imagem de uma escola
atual de hoje de agora
o e as diferenças são algumas pequenas
são poucas quem faz a diferença tem que
ser alguém que é o professor da sala de
aula neste último ano e meio todos nós
tivemos esta sala de aula na nossa casa
ou maioria de nós teve foi um ano e meio
de experiências extraordinárias de
perceber o que se passa na escola porque
as imagens entraram nossa casa as
imagens tocarmos que tivemos que
resolver um problema de escola está
fechada temos que ter os nossos filhos
em casa e temos que ajudá-los da melhor
forma
é só que escola que nós temos não estará
penso eu totalmente preparada para estes
tempos e para esses desafios por isso é
que a um plano chamado plano de
transmissão digital que todos ouvimos
todos temos opiniões durante estes
tempos em que os alunos estiveram em
casa da melhor forma tivemos situações
extraordinárias tivemos situações muito
tristes tivemos de tudo porque todos
fomos chamados a intervir na escola
aquilo que Muitos pais fizeram durante
muitos anos deixam filho na escola sem e
depois vão ficar lá a noite problema da
escola esse problema veio para de nossa
casa e como é que nós resolvemos agora
como é que os dentes nossos filhos e
como é que temos a tecnologia para isso
não temos como é que tudo isso resolvi
ouvir o situações extraordinárias a
sociedade foi chamado a intervir criar
aos movimentos de apoio os alunos com
oferta de equipamentos empresas mexermos
todos encontraram uma a resolver isto se
bem se lembram e a memória não é tão não
está tão longe Quanto isso que dê uma
sexta-feira uma quinta ou na sexta-feira
para uma segunda dissemos a escolas vão
encerrar na segunda e as aulas começam
na segunda nas vossas casas
e foi algo de extraordinário o quem
chamaram os professores heróis não sei
onde estão essas pessoas chamaram heróis
as pessoas que desapareceram já estão na
sala de aula regressaram ao presencial
já não há Heróis A pessoas estão na sala
com os problemas mas chamaram heróis
esses professores que conseguiram sem
condições fazer isso
é obviamente que transformar uma escola
é algo que demora imenso tempo a
educação tem um problema ao Contrário de
outras áreas das engenharias outras
áreas que nada acontece de um dia para o
outro educação demora gerações a mudar e
quando uma escola tem que mudar o tempo
de mudança da escola não é o tempo de
uma lança da sociedade a sociedade mudou
adaptou-se mexeu ao terão aquilo que
estava a fazer as escolas demoram mais
tempo mas curiosamente que meus dizia de
uma sexta-feira para uma segunda a
escola mudou de sítio ou problemas todos
nós sabemos sobre questões mas não parou
a escola nem todos os alunos tiveram
acesso a ela não é verdade o problemas
dramáticos mas esse problema já existiam
porque havia alunos que não tinham
acesso à escola e portanto é que estão
aqui passa por nós percebemos o seguinte
e o que é uma transição e aquilo que eu
defendo O que é a integração do digital
na escola e a Minha tese é muito simples
não a transmissão digital nas escolas
não pode haver tradição nós não podemos
transitar de um sistema digamos
analógico por um digital não há porque a
escola não muda assim não é por nós
colocarmos computadores na sala de aula
e já mudamos a escola para mudarmos a
escola não podemos transitar tem que uma
situação que eu chamo para a nossa
visão é a nossa leitura Tem que haver
integração as mudanças na escola fazem
senão por revoluções mas por integração
daquilo que é melhor que o mundo nos
pode dar e a tecnologia está em muitas
áreas temos aqui integrá-la na escola
como é que nós fazemos isso
temos que fazer com os peritos da
educação com os professores os
professores é que tem que fazer essa
integração o que tem que se organizar
com essa com essa integração nós temos
que procurar aquilo que a sociedade que
o desenvolvimento e as inovações que
existem termos de tecnologia tempo que
nos apropriar disso e no nosso papel de
professor fazer a melhor integração
possível não adianta colocar a melhor
aplicação do mundo se eu não souber
utilizar para que ela me dizer se eu não
saber utilizar E é isso que os
professores tem que fazer e é isso que
as pessoas precisam de fazer é a melhor
tecnologia aquela que eu sei usar e que
vou usar na sala de aula integrar
significa isso mesmo adaptar significa
procurar que há de melhor e trazer esse
melhor para o nosso mundo porque os
homens precisam disso porque a sociedade
precisa disso porque a escola é uma
oportunidade única que nós temos de
tocar dos alunos ninguém repete a escola
pode repetir um ano dois de escolaridade
mas da escola termina quando sai o
ensino superior ou quando deixam a
escola O que é preciso é perceber que
nós só temos uma oportunidade na vida de
tocar aqueles alunos de dares o melhor
que nós conseguimos dar para que ele
quando sair da escola se possa integrar
na sociedade é esse o papel
e essa tecnologia existe e os heróis
existem e foram estes heróis que não
tendo recursos não havendo recursos se
colocaram no carro Isto é aquelas
imagens que a televisão durante aquele
período passou que foram muito tocantes
e foram marcantes obviamente de perceber
que os professores e alunos para poderem
continuar a aceder a escola tiveram
estar em situações das mais esta
situação e esta imagem que está
passou-se na Maia nós estamos a falar no
Portugal profundo temos a falar aqui
muito perto de uma zona
que que facilmente teria a sexta mas não
há e só estes heróis destes professores
heróis e os alunos heróis que resolveram
o problema e resolver o problema porque
não tiveram quem os ajudasse porque nós
espalhamos como sociedade Neste e nos
outros porque não estávamos preparados e
a minha pergunta é mas não tivemos
oportunidade de Nos preparar não tivemos
tempo e para a para isto a tecnologia já
existe há muitos anos o digital já está
disponível lá muitos anos para todos nós
já podemos ter integrado nas escolas
soluções na sociedade soluções nas
famílias soluções que permitissem que os
alunos nesta situação ou noutra tivessem
acesso à escola porque nós continuamos
infelizmente a pensar a escola como um
espaço fixo uma sala de aula onde o que
se passa lá dentro fica lá dentro e hoje
a escola não é isso A escola está fora
da escola a escola está muito mais fora
da escola do cliente da sala de aula e
quando nós nos prendemos aquilo que é o
espaço escola tradicional tradicional
estamos a perder e a perder tempo porque
nós tínhamos existe tecnologias existem
aplicações existem dispositivos há
muitos anos tivéssemos feito essa
integração antecipada agora não teríamos
tantos problemas O que houve algumas
Ilhas felizmente bastante até onde foi a
fazer essa integração da tecnologia que
ela já estava integrada quando nos foram
para casa a solução já estava criada
quando estiveram que estar em casa a ter
aulas foi possível a escola Continuará a
acompanhar porque tinha tecnologia para
isso tinha digital para isso
e esta imagem que estou a ver desta sala
é muito bonita é um facto Ainda bem e é
com o espaço nós temos um espaço
agradável é o espaço Real de uma escola
pública que tem este espaço já antes da
pandemia mas não é só questão de espaço
é questão de pensar as aulas de forma
diferente pensar que os dispositivos
móveis que a tecnologia tem que estar ao
serviço dos alunos e os professores e
ele tem que ter experimentado porque
ninguém consegue começar a utilizar uma
tecnologia digital tenha ter
experimentado e quando nós falamos de
festa para segunda fizemos muito correu
mal tinha correr que nem toda a gente
estava preparada e é esse papel que a
escola tem que ter esse papel é tão mais
importante se vendo que há três
condições fundamentais para que a escola
tenha sucesso nesta integração do
digital três condições primeira condição
ter uma estrutura digital quando eu falo
uma estrutura significa ter plataformas
de comunicação ter plataformas de
arquivo de materiais de a promoção da
ligação com os olhos mas não é para
quando eles estão em casa confinados é
para utilizar no dia a dia na sala de
aula para dar continuidade para aquele
aluno que está doente o que não vem a
escola possa ter sempre acesso a essa
informação em formato digital essa
estrutura tem que ser muito bem
planejada pela escola mas não só tem que
haver condições a nível Nacional a
título de exemplo para quem é mais a
tecnologia hoje é possível ter um
servidor na Cloud nuvem porque é que
havemos de servidores na escola físicos
que exigem recursos existem técnicos
especializados para obter é uma solução
simples podemos ter o servidor e as
escolas a serem e serviu para todos os
seus filhos tem que haver uma estrutura
com equipamentos com esta base permite
de facto de chegar mais rapidamente ao
soluços a segunda condição é obviamente
tem a ver com a aquilo que é a
existência de conteúdos
e os conteúdos que dizem na escola todos
conhecemos ou a maioria deles que são os
manuais em papel que estão disponíveis
para utilizados nos cursos digitais não
são reproduções em PDF dos manuais tem
que ser interativo tem que ser
Multimédia tem que ser multi-plataformas
tem que ser adaptáveis pelo próprio de
soro só assim é que o professor consegue
estrutura conteúdos esses conteúdos
estão disponíveis nós temos editoras
fazem do mais avançado que há no mundo
em termos de recursos digitais que estão
disponíveis para todos temos do Topo e
podemos usar os eles estão disponíveis e
as editoras fizeram isso durante a pena
amiga finalmente o que é que se torna
necessário e obrigatório formação para
os professores a um plano de Formação
plano de formação para transmissão
digital eu percebi que chamasse
integração digital está em conjunto
todos os professores e nós somos um dos
únicos países na Europa e no mundo fez
uma avaliação das competências digitais
de luz uma ao O que são os professores
foram todos convidados a responder uma
ferramenta o cheque no questionário onde
tiveram que responder relativamente a
sua ao seu entendimento um diagnóstico
daquilo que é a sua ferramenta e temos
esse retrato do país tanto agora aqui da
formação que está desenvolvida estar ser
implementada por todo lado e esta
formação de facto é aquilo que pode
mudar se os professores a entenderá como
uma formação para evoluir o pior e
aquilo que infelizmente está acontecer
em algumas escolas eu não vou fazer aqui
uma estatística não fiz um estudo da
minha experiência de uma conhecimento
é que muitos estão a voltar aquilo que
eu chamo a fotocópia deixou de ser
necessário digital voltaram a fotocópia
e dizendo temos que voltar ao normal
temos que voltar ao normal não anormal
voltar ao normal a voltar ao passado já
não temos mais normal o que era antes
evoluiu alterou-se não há regresso É
verdade ao Regresso a uma nova realidade
EA nessa nova realidade que nós temos
que evoluir E só vamos conseguir evoluir
tivermos consciência que não pobre não
há regresso ao passar do tempo este tema
no bom é isso temos de fazer Temos que
esquecer o passado o que foi aprendemos
o presidente do que aprender muito a
custo com muitos problemas mas Mônico
temos que pensar no presente
antecipando o futuro e aquilo que
fizermos hoje será com certeza um
resultado muito melhor do que ficarmos
arraigados ao que era ao saudosismo ao
pensar no meu tempo é que era bom ou a
escola era boa não antigamente é a
escola que temos EA escola que temos
aquilo que fazemos e que nós fizemos já
hoje eu costumo dizer hoje é tarde para
usar e levar o digital para a escola já
é tarde estamos a pé é importante não
vamos perder mais tempo muito bom vamos
para a frente e eu tenho expectativa que
facto que isso seja possível tudo bem
com um pouquinho de reticências com
alguns exemplos envolvente Infelizmente
mas a esperança existe uma avancemos um
futuro é hoje não é no futuro Muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]